The Joe Rogan experience.
Are you from military background?
My Dad,
yeah.
My Dad was,
so that's what my parents met.
My Dad was stationed in Germany.
My mom was fleeing Thailand,
um,
to,
uh,
her,
her first husband was like physically abusive to her,
so she was leaving Thailand and she came to Germany to find her a Gi and then
found my dad to find a Gi specifically.
Well,
you know,
I think she was coming to get away,
but you know,
she wanted to,
she wanted a better life for her son at the time.
And my dad was in the hospital and so my mom was taking care of them and cooking
them food and made him fall in love.
There you go.
It,
my dad always jokes,
he says,
he tells us a story all the time.
He's like,
yeah,
your mom was taking care of me.
And then she told me that you were pregnant and then 12 months later you were
born.
Oh,
that's funny.
So,
but now they fell in love.
It was just a really long pregnancy.
This weird,
just kind of weird.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
12 months.
I don't know
what a character,
Redd Foxx,
Edwin,
he wouldn't pay his taxes.
So the government came down one night when he,
all the people in the room just took everything,
everything,
went to his house,
took everything.
He took a ring off his finger and he took his shoes.
They took it and never,
never my chicken raw to cook in the oven.
And so he,
they shut him down is the place he had I think don't Los Anica somewhere.
It was in la and la yet.
Um,
so he crying.
Oh God.
He called Sammy Davis.
He Call Sandy called Frank Sinatra.
And he [inaudible] took everyday now own.
I worked so hard to be who I am.
I am.
I am doing.
I just,
I only texted anything that bad that they took everything.
So Frank Sinatra and Sammy Davis junior and some other other friends,
uh,
went to his club and work two or three weeks every night.
Two shows,
sold them out to get enough money to pay,
get his taxes and get his club back.
[inaudible] he was so happy to everybody's,
Oh my God.
I want to thank you for doing with this for me.
Oh,
please just take my dick,
my,
my hood.
Let me just hug you.
Hugging everybody.
So they all went on our separate ways with Fox.
Still in pays fucking Texas.
No,
I come again with lean on his A's.
You son of a bitch.
You do.
They want [inaudible] name.
But I coming back now,
see,
oh my God,
we'll pay taxes again.
He paid no taxes.
Was this before or after Sanford and son?
It was before.
And I bet,
I don't think he paid after San Fran.
He believed it paid on Texas.
My money
pay my taxes.
I mean,
you don't cater to your craft and maintaining it is,
there's an art to that,
right?
Because you worked so freaking hard to get to where you're at and then get there
and it's
like,
oh fuck,
what do I do?
Like there's no rest.
There's no rest.
And everything that was acceptable before becomes unacceptable because now
you're up here.
Uh,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
yeah,
you have to,
you have to pick your shots.
And like,
you know what I'm saying?
Can't really like,
just go crazy like you did back in the day.
So there's an art to it,
you know what I mean?
And that's how you really maintain and stay in that spot and even level up.
So do you consciously think,
okay,
a balance out enjoyment with things that I have to do to stay disciplined?
100% yeah,
100% that's a very smart way of looking at it.
Yeah.
Yup.
100% like those,
there has to be a balance of each because it's like,
all right,
now I'm at this new level,
like whether I want to behave like this or not.
I put myself here,
I worked hard,
now I'm with these elite motherfuckers.
So this is the,
this is how I have to act because I'm not down here anymore.
I worked from here to get here.
So what happens?
You balanced,
you put things into place,
you do a little bit of this and a little bit in that instead of a lot of that,
you know what I mean?
And you just pick your shots and it's like you're going to get everything in the
end.
This is how it's just planning how it's supposed to be,
but you just piece it together just a little bit differently.
Like I just turned 31 walk down.
I'm about to be 32 as young too.
A lot of people that's old to some people as well,
but for me it's like this a whole new mind state,
you know what I mean?
And I feel like through my twenties I was actually like a fucking teenager and
like now I'm an adult.
So now I look at things a little bit differently.
It's like,
Yo,
I was really a kid.
This is how you behave as an adult for the rest of your life.
And it still involves a whole bunch of partying and having fun,
but the business gets handled and things get approached totally differently.
That's a balanced way of looking at it,
man.
I love it and enjoy it.
That's how they think too.
Like people have to understand too,
to be someone like you,
to be a very successful rapper and to not expect you to live the way you talk
about all the time.
It's so ridiculous.
Right,
right,
right.
Like you don't think he wants to party.
He's talking about party all the time.
I think he wants to party [inaudible] party.
This is just an act.
It's weird,
right?
It's crazy as fuck because people,
they want you to be you.
They want me to be myself.
Right.
They want to party.
They want to take shots,
they want to smoke weed.
They want to stay up all night.
Yeah.
Why is that bad?
It's not so many people want to do it,
but it gives us a image in some people's minds like frivolous life.
Mm.
Frivolous thinking,
partying.
What are you doing?
Drinking and smoking.
What are you enjoying yourself?
And then they come around and do the same thing cause they want it.
It's like I have like a weird place in life where I think I'm like the key to a
lot of shit because it's like if you want to enjoy yourself,
I'm a guy.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
aw man,
I'm just fucking going to live through wisdom where it shows up.
He's going to light.
The joint is going to be amazing if you want to fucking be professional,
like especially in what I do,
because there's a whole lot of rappers who like aren't business,
you know what I mean?
They're not thinking like that.
So for those guys,
I'm their guy.
Like they're they,
they look at me like where's has his shit together?
Like he really handles his business.
He talks to people,
he shows up,
he does this,
he does that.
So to be the party guy and the business guy,
it's like amazing.
You know what I mean?
It's a,
it's a lane that I kind of car for myself,
but it's me in real life.
So it's like,
that's the only thing I have to do is really just completely be myself.
Just be 100 fucking show up.
Do my business thing.
Tell people,
do the right thing and fucking light to join.
[inaudible] that's it.
It's a crazy business,
sir.
I'm,
I'm good.
I'm straight like that.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Yup.
People listening to this are probably,
wow.
He could beat yourself or a living for a show bros.
Blessing.
It's a blessing.
We were at you ever,
you ever do a podcast and the above,
the comedy cellar,
they've got a studio up there.
Bobby Kelly started it and it's a,
I forget what it's called.
And um,
so I'm up there doing my podcast with Ari and it's an apartment.
It's like there's a,
there's a bedroom and a bathroom and in the studio,
and we got to talking about torture.
And I go,
uh,
I go,
you ever been waterboarded?
He's like,
no,
I go,
this is a bathroom right here.
you want it?
You want me to waterboard you?
And you know Ari's like,
Yep,
sure,
let's do it.
So we go inside and I put a towel over his face and he leans over backwards in
his head is below his body in the shower stall,
the nozzle comes off the wall and I spray down his face and,
uh,
nothing,
nothing.
And then all of a sudden his bodies convulsing,
his legs are kicking,
he's fucking screaming,
water is shooting out of his nose.
He's choking.
And it went on for like a couple of minutes and I'm fucking dying.
And then he starts laughing and we were just on the podcast laughing without
saying a word for probably five minutes.
And then he goes,
well,
I'm going to do it to you.
I'm like,
fuck yeah.
And then he waterboarded me in the same thing happened.
Wow.
Yeah.
Blow waterboarding's legit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can't,
that's real torture.
Yeah.
But it's weird torture cause you're not permanently injuring someone.
Like can you think of towards you think of like someone cutting someone?
Yeah.
Lighting them on fire,
Shit like that.